[Applause]
so exactly what is drew's news
we like to say it's the news served
sunny side up
so let's see what made the papers okay
first up this summer i was really
honored to be on the cover of instyle
magazine and my old friend
laura brown who's the editor-in-chief
allowed me to wear one of my personal
vintage t-shirts on the cover
fun fact magazines make money by
featuring designers
on their covers and it's a form of
advertising and revenue for them
but we got to break the rules
by wearing this detroit news t-shirt
after that the detroit news saw this and
reissued them because they weren't
making these anymore as a part of a
fundraising effort
for detroit area college scholarships
well yesterday the detroit news itself
reported that sales of the shirt have
raised over
70 thousand dollars
i mean things are possible
that's what the evidence of this is so
if you'd like to contribute head over to
our website for a link and all the
proceeds
go directly to the rosa all park
scholarship foundation
so let's do this let's raise more money
do some good
this is evidence it's happening okay
now seriously i don't like to get into
controversial items on drew's news but
i'm going to have to tackle this next
issue head on it's a debate that's gone
viral this week
on twitter and it continues to heat up
more and more each day and the question
is
if a giraffe were to wear a bow tie
where would the bow tie go
i'm vacillating i think we can all agree
it just looks better up top
a pop of color to accentuate the eyes
but if you think about it humans wear a
bow tie at the bottom of their neck as
part of the outfit
okay we have some opposing views with
our virtual
friends david and alex you have varying
opinions let's hear them out loud david
you go first
what you i gotta say i think the bow tie
goes up closer to the top
just makes more sense there yeah i hear
you alex rebuttal
hi drew sorry i'm just really excited to
talk to you oh i'm excited to talk to
you too
um but i actually feel very confident
answering this question i
am a designer in the fashion industry
so an authority
i personally have never seen anybody
wear a bow tie
under their chin i don't know about
david
but i personally believe that it needs
to be down by the shoulders
if it is worn properly i hear you both
it's a tough call but i'm going to go
with my gut
on this one either way giraffes should
wear bow ties
wherever they want and plain old fun
okay you do you giraffes and thanks alex
and david you're the best
all right debate settled finally it's no
secret we love good news here
and this story is a perfect example of
the good we need in the world
tyler and melanie are newlyweds from
parma ohio
need to cancel their wedding you know
because of everything that's happening
and rather than get a refund for all the
catering they decided to donate the food
to a local shelter
and it is so wonderful we just had to
talk to them so
hello tyler and melanie thank you for
coming on the show
[Applause]
oh we're excited to be here this is
crazy i'm just more excited we kind of
match
by the way we totally do in fact we're
kind of wearing
bows if you get what i'm saying everyone
you're louder though i didn't even
realize this okay
this is all so serendipitous all right
well and
uh before we get into the amazing thing
that you did
i just have to know how you guys met
so we actually met at our friend's
wedding uh
we were partnered up i kind of feel like
they did that on purpose
um but we actually had a moment during
it uh we were taking pictures
and i fell into him and we kind of both
just stood there
and i think at that moment we both kind
of were like oh we kind of have this
spark
so we went with it and here we are
do you know oh sorry go ahead
no no no i was just gonna say it was a
magical moment
it truly was do you know how how many
people like get dressed up and go to a
wedding with so much hope you know
i mean you guys are kind of proving that
things are really possible and to keep
hope alive
okay so rather than canceling the
catering you donated
this to a local shelter why did you do
this
well i mean we were working with uh with
the caterer for
quite some time and we've gotten um to
be pretty good friends with them
actually and when covet hit um you know
all the local businesses started to
really take a hit
and we felt terrible that they were
going to lose out
so you know every year we donate
somewhere typically around christmas
uh to children's we get different gifts
for them
um for for under privilege so the way
things lined up
um it just seemed right for us to donate
the food and help somebody out
oh i think you guys are just so amazing
and
i heard a rumor that she bought a new
house we
did uh we've been here for like three
months now
it's a little bit of a fixer-upper um we
had a pizza's whole room
it was wonderful um but yeah we're
really excited
uh we our neighbors are amazing they
have babies so we get to play with them
it's so much fun so well this
is perfect because i wanted to give you
a wedding gift
we are going to give you a i love design
so much i have a furniture company
called flower home and today we want to
gift you a five thousand dollar
credit for flower homes you can get
anything you want as you begin
your life together and if you want
anna and francesca who are the creative
directors and i design
everything with they're the coolest
women we are all going to personally
help you
put it together to make your space
perfect so
thank you for being here and sharing
your story
don't cry normally so here i am
thanks you guys so much tyra banks is
next we'll be right back thank you
we want to make your dream home
you